peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la peste fait partie de notre histoire
comme les famines comme les guerres elle
a ravagé l'europe et la terrorisés
pendant quatre siècles faisant des
dizaines de millions de morts de 13 148
à 1720 pendant ces quatre siècles
personnes quittent presque l'accusa les
rats ni les puces il y à 80 ans
seulement que yersin identifia le germe
de la peste et 76 ans seulement que
simon à bombay découvrit que la peste
maladie du rat et de quelques autres
rongeurs s'était transmise à l'homme par
la puce incapable de comprendre pendant
ces quatre siècles le mal qu'il est
frappante foule qu'il est fou droit qui
rend les morts dans une ville plus
présent que les vivants les hommes vont
imaginer des causes étrange à ce mal
contre lequel ils ne trouvent qu'un
remède et qui souvent n'en est pas un la
fuite
[Musique]
reut pendant longtemps la peste sera une
maladie de l'air l'air empester il faut
en changer
fuir
[Musique]
m
oui l'événement est absolument inouïe il
bouleverse une grande partie du monde
habité afrique asie mais surtout
l'europe
ce que nous savons c'est que dès le
premier coup la peste a tué entre un
quart et un tiers de la population de
l'europe c'est-à-dire probablement entre
15 et 20 millions d'habitants
un homme une femme un enfant sur trois
qui en quelques mois son rayon parmi les
premières villes touchées par la peste
en fait 148 le la plus grande
c'est florence comment est-ce que la
peste est arrivé est bien la peste comme
presque tout ce qui arrive en europe en
occident est venue de lorient enfin 347
nous savons que des bateaux génois
viennent de kafa avec des pestiférés et
se présente devant gêne avec leurs morts
et leurs malades
les génois sans savoir de quoi il s'agit
on la réaction de prudence qui l'ont
d'ailleurs dans toutes leurs affaires
ils refusent l'entrée des bateaux les
bateaux poursuivre leur route
les marseillais moins prudents les
accepte et de marseille
la peste va monter se répandre envahir
tout l'occident de la chrétienté
ici encore il y a des imprudents comme
les marseillais
ce sont les gens de pise qui accueille
des bateaux venus de messine et peas
c'est en quelque sorte l'avant-port
c'est tout près de florence
et depuis voilà la peste
parmi les florentins qui survivent il ya
par chance pocas oui boccace qui sous
l'effet de la peste des treize 149 écrit
les nouvelles qui seront terminés en 13
153 et constitue le fameux decameron or
le decameron est ancré dans la peste
parce que les femmes qui se racontent
ces nouvelles sont de riches florentine
qui ont fui la peste dans les villas de
la campagne et au début du decameron il
y a la plus belle description de la
peste de très simple a ensuite on était
déjà parvenu en 1348 quand la cité de
florence noble entre les plus fameuses
de l'italie fut tombera l'épidémie
mortelle
d'aucuns ces figures est qu une vie
sobre et l'abstention de tout superflu
s'imposer pour combattre une attaque si
redoutable
d'autres se conduisaient différemment ça
donnait franchement à la boisson comme
jouissance accorder toute satisfaction
possible à leurs patients étaient selon
leurs propos le remède le plus sûr
contre un mal c'est atroce
d'aucuns manifester plus de cruauté mais
peut-être plus de prudence
il disait que le plus sûr garante contre
les germes du mâle était la fuite
le désastre a végété temps de froid au
coeur des hommes des femmes que le frère
abandonné le frère l'anc les neveux la
soeur le frère souvent même la femme le
mari
voici que plus fort est à peine croyable
les pères et mères comme si leur enfant
n'était plus à éviter de léser les voir
et de les aider les menus peuvent et
peut-être une grande partie de la classe
moyenne offrait d'ailleurs les
spectacles d'une misère infiniment plus
douloureuse n'aurait selon ni secours ni
service d'aucune sorte
ils mourraient autant dire sans
rémission
certains expirait de jour ou de nuit sur
la voie publique et beaucoup d'autres
bien que meurent à domicile transmettez
d'abord aux voisins l'annoncé de leur
décès par le d'heure infecte de l'arche
quand peu tour et gorgés de ces cadavres
et des cadavres d autres hommes qui
partent au mouret la cruauté du ciel est
peut-être celle des hommes fossiles et
heureuse l'épidémie s'est vidée mars à
juillet avec tant de violence
une foule de malades furent si mal c'est
que rue qu'on a quelques raisons
d'estimer à plus de 5000 le nombre
d'hommes qui perdirent la vie dans celle
de la cité
cent mille morts c'est beaucoup non oui
certainement boccace un peu exagéré en
treize 148 il doit y avoir 85 à 90
milles habitants à florence il en meurt
20 à 25 milles c'est pas mal pour un
homme de très 148 la peste d'une maladie
entièrement nouvelle oui elle est
entièrement nouvelle d'abord parce que
il n'y a pratiquement pas eu d'épidémie
de peste
avant il y a eu une première épidémie
général aussi du 6e au 8e siècle qui a
frappé la plus grande partie de l'europe
du haut moyen-âge la peste de justinien
et de grégoire le grand puisque l'un est
empereur et l'autre pape à ce moment là
mais cette peste est oublié elle a été
très peu connu à son époque complètement
oublié de pluie est en trés 148 la peste
c'est une nouveauté inouïe et d'autant
plus terrifiante et pourtant les
responsables de florence on parlait du
barde j'ai de l'eau se préoccupe des
épidémies oui ce mur représente bien
toute sa hauteur et sa puissance la
force de la ville de florence la force
de son pot des stades capitaine du
peuple alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
cet homme qu'est ce que tous ces gens
que ce que les responsables de la ville
ont fait contre la peste lui un ces gens
là qui représente un effet la puissance
du peuple contre les aristocrates depuis
le milieu du xiiie siècle est une chose
qui est assez étonnante c'est que nous
sommes ici dans la ville qui est sans
doute le mieux organisé pour faire face
à un cataclysme une catastrophe de ce
genre
en effet dès le début du 14e siècle
entre 13 120 à 130 alors que la peste
est inconnu imprévus ils ont déjà pris
ce que l'on appelle des règlements
sanitaires des stats outils sanitary où
ils ont prévu à la fois les problèmes de
ravitaillement et également des mesures
d'hygiène et chose très étonnante
ils réagissent avec une extraordinaire
rapidité la peste nous savons arrive en
mars 13 148 à florence et dès le 3 avril
le podestat en vertu des statuts
sanitaire fait interdire la
fréquentation des génois et d'epizon
c'est à dire des gens qui ont amené la
peste fait surveiller les marchés parce
que on pense qu'il ya une liaison entre
l'alimentation et la peste est il
interdit que l'on vende des objet ayant
appartenu aux pestiférés
c'est à dire que déjà pour eux l'idée de
contagion est un fed il est otage on est
un fait pour le peuple
la contagion est la chose évidente dans
cette maladie quant aux médecins ils
posent des problèmes
il pose des problèmes parce que on peut
dire qu'en fait ce sont eux qui
comprennent le moins ce qui se passe
vous dire contre 148 la peste monte en
europe et les personnes - florence par
conséquent mai
en france aussi déjà un peu en
angleterre et que la sorbonne et
consulté et la sorbonne donne une
réponse assez curieuse c'est une réponse
de gens qui sont plus des théologiens
que des médecins
ils ont lu dans l'évangile que un
cataclysme est précédée par des
tremblements de terre que la terre s'en
trouvera que laisse échapper nerfs
maléfique et aussi des animaux maléfique
en particulier des serpents et des
grenouilles
l'idée que c'est l'air qui est empester
porte un nom savant l'aeri sme
cette doctrine n'est pas sans
conséquence elle empêche de croire à la
contagion en la contagion est une
évidence pour tout le monde sauf pour
les médecins à quelques exceptions près
gui de chauliac par exemple la reconnaît
la forme la plus courante de la peste
boccace l'a décrite ainsi chez nous au
début de l'épidémie certaines enflure se
produisait allen ou sous l'aisselle les
unes devenait grosses comme des pommes
ordinaire d'autres comme un oeuf
d'autres un peu plus ou un peu moins on
les appelait vulgairement but bons
essais bubons ne tardèrent pas pour
semer la mort à grossir indifféremment
sur n'importe quelle partie du corps
on a maladie on connaît ses symptômes
est ce qu'elle paraît naturel ou non
bien entendu elle elle attaque les corps
mais le problème c'est de savoir
pourquoi et comment et le pourquoi
ou bien entendu pour des hommes du 14e
siècle il est religieux c'est la colère
de dieu
l'humanité et mais serait-ce et dieu
veut l'achat dit il lâche hâtives en
envoyant les cavaliers de l'apocalypse
avec leurs flèches qui frappe les hommes
et la peste et vu ainsi comme une flèche
inexorable
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
on invoque la vierge parce que la vierge
de ces l'intercesseur habituel elle
prend son grand manteau et les flèches
viennent se ficher et l'humanité est
ainsi protégé à l'intérieur du manteau
il y a cette explication colère divine
mais il ya dans ces cas là il y a eu
effectivement des boucs bien sûr parce
que dieu n'agit jamais directement
il a des intermédiaires humain il s'agit
donc de savoir qui sur l'ordre de dieu
concrètement apporte la paix est le
bouc-émissaire principal ray c'est le
juif une vague d'antisémitisme
formidable dans l'accusent les juifs de
jeter de la poudre empoisonné dans les
fontaines ses terres le résultat c'est
un nombre considérable de programmes
oui il ya des choses épouvantables on en
connaît ici et là par exemple à
strasbourg
la moitié de la communauté juive et
brûlé il ya peut-être plus horrible
encore aspire par exemple en allemagne
les juifs qu'ils sentent qu'ils vont
être massacrés se renferme dans la
synagogue il met le feu et se font
brûler eux mêmes
il ya une chose qui m'a frappé c'est que
alors que la peste sévit partout non
seulement en europe mais également en
afrique du nord et dans les pays
d'orient aucun chroniqueur arabe ne
mentionne le fait que des juifs ont été
persécutés comme responsable de la peste
en dehors de l'europe
oui il y a fait toute une géographie de
l'antisémitisme le monde arabe
à ce moment là le monde musulman n'est
pas antisémite et à l'intérieur même du
monde chrétien
il y à des nuances le pape par exemple
fait paraître un texte disant qu' il est
peu vraisemblable que les juifs soient
un responsable de la peste puisque même
en sont frappés et meurt
[Musique]
autres victimes les suspects ce qui en
pleine épidémie ne sont pas malades dans
un quartier où tout le monde est frappé
en fait c'est leur métier qui les sauve
les puces même pas l'odeur de l'huile
l'odeur des chèvres l'odeur du cheval
aussi les barbiers les marches en huile
les bergers décoché sont épargnés donc
suspect donc unis
[Musique]
à l'opposé du monde de surf à l'opposé
de ces pogroms il ya une ferveur pieux
bien sûr parce qu'il a subi il ya aussi
ceux qui ne vont pas chercher des boucs
émissaires en dehors des chrétiens
eux-mêmes et qu'ils pensent que les
grands responsables ce sont les
chrétiens par leurs péchés et qu' il
faut donc que des pénitences ait lieu
parmi les chrétiens et des petits
groupes se charge d'être pour l'ensemble
du peuple chrétien des sacrificateurs de
même ce sont les fameux flagellant
outils s'en vont parler bout et qui se
frappent avec des fouets pour apaiser
lieux et essayer de faire ainsi arrêter
la peste en fait les flagellant même
seront eux-mêmes arrêtés dans leur
démarche assez rapidement d'abord parce
que souvent il apporte la paix est avec
eux et puis parce qu'ils vont trop loin
finalement le roi de le roi de france
les interdire oui enfin c'est surtout
l'église qui est inquiète de ces formes
extrêmes qui peuvent déraper vers les
rythmes usagers dans cette même une
exception évidemment j'imagine que la
carte éthique général c'est plutôt la
nie que les flagellant soir l'exception
sans doute la panique je ne sais pas la
peur elle viendra quand ça recommencera
tous les dix quinze ans en toscane de
360 374 parce que là ce moment là entre
148 on a vu une chose louis en
cataclysme dont on penser que pour une
fois pour toutes du aurait piqué une
colère terrible il se serait terminée et
puis ça recommence
et puis ça recommence encore et
désormais on se demandera quand ça finir
à
[Musique]
d'ailleurs les municipalités même si
elle essaie de faire quelque chose
souvent minimise l'événement ou même
cherche à le passer sous silence les
chroniques de certaines villes ont été
décimés par la peste sont muettes sur
l'événement comme si ce silence était
exorcise ateurs à les faire disparaître
le fléau de lui même maintenant si nous
nous tournons vers les réactions
individuelles par exemple celle des gens
de ce palais le palais d'avant sahati un
des rares qui soient restés du 14e
siècle ses murs ont vu la peste on peut
dire que l'ensemble des attitudes
individuelles se polarise vers deux
extrémités d'une part le mysticisme
l'ascétisme la folie mystique et
religieuses qui va marquer cette époque
du moyen âge et qui va vers la réforme
de l'autre côté au contraire le saut
dans le plaisir
les folles fait qu'ils annoncent elles
aussi celle de la renaissance est entre
les deux ce contraste cette
extraordinaire tension cas si bien senti
le célèbre historien 8 un gars dans son
automne du moyen-âge cet automne fait de
ce contraste entre l'odeur des roses et
demi du sang
à
[Musique]
ce que les gens voient
c'est tout simplement ce qu'ils ont sous
les yeux et qui ne leur laisse pas le
temps de réfléchir ceux qui voient ce
sont les gens qui meurent coup sur coup
les cadavres qui s'amoncellent les
maisons mais qui deviennent plein de ces
cadavres mais que parfois on ne songe
même pas aller chercher car il n'y a
plus personne de vivant dans la maison
il faut que l'odeur décèlent la présence
de ces cadavres
et puis on meurt dans les cours on meurt
dans les rues et après il y à aussi
l'évacuation de ces cadavres
au début on fait ce que l'on peut avec
les croque morts
mais bientôt on est obligé de mettre
plusieurs cadavres dans un cercueil
et puis on manque de cercueil on emporte
les cadavres dans des linges on les
porte dans les cimetières
les cimetières sont trop petits ils sont
plus à leur tour on creuse des fosses
communes et tous florence et les
environs et bientôt dans presque toute
l'europe
cet immense char mais il n'en reste pas
moins qu'il n'ya pendant ces trois
siècles une constante têtu qui veut que
on y come on come on a nié comme on a
interdit la peut on il atteste de la
contagion on ne veut pas que la peste
oui ceci au niveau scientifique
il reste que non seulement il y à ces
réactions immédiates des gens dont nous
avons parlé mais que bientôt il va y
avoir des mesures des municipalités des
pouvoirs publics qui reprendront ce qui
avait déjà été fait au septième siècle
qui est d'essayer de barrer la route à
la maladie avec par exemple la fermeture
des portes des villes aux paysans aux
vagabonds à tous les itinérants et si la
peste fait fuir hors de la ville ceux
qui le peuvent
il y aura aussi comme un grand
renfermement à l'intérieur de ces villes
qui
deviennent ces charniers immobile
que de grand palais que de belles
maisons que ne demeure autrefois plein
de domestique de seigneurs et de dames
et enfin disparaître jusqu'aux plus
humble serviteur que d'illustrés famille
que d'imposants domaine que de fortune
réputé restèrent privé des héritiers
légitimes
et un rapport entre la peste cette
vierge
oui parce que ce thème au milieu du 14e
siècle
c'est un thème tout nouveau c'est celui
de la vierge de l'humilité c'est une des
formes de sensibilité née de la peste de
qui donne à ce rapport entre la mère et
l'enfant à cette sensibilité familière
une très grande portée mais il ne
faudrait pas croire que c'est la
réaction est essentielle au contraire
les autres réactions vont plutôt en sens
inverse est bien plus terrible comment
peut-on caractérisé temps de paix est
une expression que je dirais volontiers
que c'est le temps de la dissolution des
solidarités médiévale bien sûr ce qui
fera peut-être le plus c'est
l'aggravation des antagonismes entre les
classes sociales les riches et les
pauvres les riches accuse les pauvres
les pauvres accuse les riches et ceux
qui frappent les chroniqueurs de
l'époque c'est que entre 148 il semble
que il meurt plus de pauvres que de
riches ce qui probablement vrai
d'abord parce qu'ils sont plus
s'entassent et que la contagion il fait
plus de ravages
et puis la plupart d'entre eux ne
peuvent pas s'enfuir mais je crois quand
même que le grand phénomène c'est celui
de cette disparition presque immédiate
de ces solidarités sur lesquels étaient
fondées la société médiévale est d'abord
la famille la famille semble se défaire
tout d'un coup tout le monde le note à
commencer par boccace au moment de la
mort remonte la maladie et puis il ya
aussi l'impuissance de l'église est
mieux que l'emploi
de l'église le firent ce qu'on peut dire
de l'église
certes il y à des prêtres qui font leurs
devoirs
mais la plupart ou bien sont fauchés par
la mort les congrégations les couvents
aussi sont des lieux où la contagion se
déchaîne mais les autres bientôt ne même
plus non plus donné l'extrême onction
n'accompagne plus les cadavres les rites
des cérémonies funéraires ne se font
plus en 13 148 tout disparaît et un
ainsi la famille se défaisant l'église
disparaissant presque l'individu reste
seul est seul face à la mort nous voyons
avec la grande peste un moment
extraordinaire comme tournant des
attitudes de l'homme face à la mort
jusqu'à la peste
l'homme avait surtout peur de l'enfer et
à un moindre degré depuis la fin du
xiième siècle du purgatoire
désormais il y as régression de la peur
au moment même de la mort c'est le
moment où cela qu'on va se préparer dans
l' angoisse c'est ce moment terrible du
passage dont on sait qu'il peut se faire
d'une façon absolument apocalyptique
lors d'une épidémie qui sans rémission
vous emporte tout seul isolé vers la
putréfaction est désormais l'homme va
être non seulement en face de la mort
mais en face de son cadavre et même en
face de son squelette le temps des
danses macabres le xvème siècle va
arriver
[Musique]
non
le
[Musique]
nous voici après la peste et bien
entendu les phénomènes le plus
spectaculaire le plus immédiatement
catastrophique c'est les trous dans la
population
15 à 20 millions d'habitants est
probablement surtout de parmi les
pauvres d'où le premier grand problème
social et économique qui est le problème
de la main d'oeuvre et dresserait 149
les salaires montent mais la réaction
des pouvoirs des classes dirigeantes et
brutale les municipalités urbaines ici
en italie et surtout là où il y a un
pouvoir central déjà plus fort en france
par exemple en angleterre les rois
bloque les prix en 353 france jour le bo
fait prononcer un blocage général des
salaires c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire une fois dans l'histoire et
on peut dire en définitive que le
résultat un petit peu paradoxal de la
peste qui a ébranlé les fondements
politiques c'est que la réaction des
pouvoirs va favoriser va accélérer la
mise en place de nouvelles structures
politiques
le prince la monarchie
la marche vers l'absolutisme s'en trouve
accélérée
ça n'empêche pas que les tensions
sociales non seulement de mer très vives
mais se renforce dans la seconde moitié
du 14e siècle qui est la grande période
des révoltes populaires
à la campagne on ne sait pas très bien
mais il est fort possible que par
exemple la fameuse jacquerie qui éclate
en france entre 156 viennent en partie
de la peste et de ces ébranlements mais
surtout c'est le grand moment des
révoltes des émeutes urbaines dont la
principale a lieu ici à florence c'est
la révolte des manoeuvres les chiang pin
13 178 et ça dure trois ans et ça
ébranle les fondements de
l'oligarchie bourgeoise je pense à cette
phrase de vos cases sur les grandes
familles décimées monde est mort il n'ya
plus d'héritier donc de nouvelles
familles se dessine bien sûr au niveau
des classes dirigeantes le grand
phénomène social c'est le renouvellement
dans l'église d'abord ici par exemple
est bien ici la peste 113 148 a tué
environ la moitié des dominicains 150
probablement renouvellement donc du
personnel dirigeant de l'église
renouvellement des grandes familles on
peut même se demander par exemple les
médicis ici à florence la famille existe
on pressent 48 les notables mais elle
est loin d'être une des plus importantes
or dans 50 60 ans elle va être maîtres
de la ville
on peut se demander si l'un peste n'est
pas pour quelque chose et si
l'effacement des plus grands n'a pas
laissé la place libre aux médicis et
quel rapport y at il entre la peste et
la chapelle qui donne sur ce toit pour
échapper d espagne cette chapelle c'est
la salle capitulaire du couvent qui
donne sur le cloître d'où nous venons et
elle a été construite après 13 148 et
surtout peintes avec cette
extraordinaire cycle de fresques grâce à
l'argent d'un des plus riches marchands
de florence dont la femme est morte de
la peste en 13 148 et qui sous le choc
de l'événement fait pénitence à sa façon
c'est à dire en donnant la plus grande
partie de son argent
la chapelle est peinte une dizaine
d'années après sa mort entre 365 et 13
170 et elle correspond aux goûts du
moment et à la politique de l'église
face à la peste
l'église elle a été surtout effrayés par
les manifestations presque hérétiques
qui se sont développés après 148
nous avons vu les flagellant il peut y
avoir pire à l'intérieur même de
l'ordre par exemple ici même en toscane
il y à la célèbre sainte catherine de
sienne tertiaire de l'ordre dominicain
qui prétend avoir des visions et que on
peut à travers des contacts personnels
avec lieu faire son salut et qui
passionne les foules et pour mettre le
holà
les dominicains ici même dans cette
salle en 13 174 convoque catherine de
sienne la faune examiner et sans doute
lui ont montré qu'elle était la bonne
voie grâce à ces fresques d'abord en
obéissant aux autorités aux autorités
religieuses et civiles ecclésiastiques
et laïque
avec tous ces personnages qui sont deux
faces comme avant durtaut le pape le
plus haut bien sûr puis l'empereur les
hauts fonctionnaires les ordres
mendiants et toute la société
depuis les riches jusqu aux pauvres et
aux mendiants et à cette société ce
qu'on lui propose d'abord c'est de ne
pas faire comme ces hérétiques juifs
musulmans ou autres comme ce symbolisée
par cellou que les chiens les
dominicains chien du seigneur sont en
train de mettre à la raison ce qu'il
faut faire
l'acte essentiel c'est la pénitence la
confession où il faut passer par
l'intermédiaire de l'église
et si possible d'un dominique qui amène
le pénitent vers saint pierre qui ouvre
la porte du paradis à l'homme qui a su
résister à la tentation de
manifestations hérétiques ou para eric
le salut en définitive
c'est le christ le christ avec la
bannière de la résurrection le christ
qui a terrassé le mal le mal symbolisée
par ce diable noir qui peut être
rappeler aux contemporains les sermons
du prieur de santa maria nouvelle le
plus grand prédicateur de son temps qui
avait dit aux florentins qu'ils avaient
bien vu et senti que le corps de l'homme
sans plus mauvais que celui des chiens
et des boucs
mais le mal si c'est la peste qui n'est
pas encore terrassé
[Musique]
pendant quatre siècles la peste n'a pas
cessé d'arriver elle est toujours là a
mené par les voyageurs les pèlerins
soldats les marches en remontant les
fleuves les routes
et si elle se calme il y a presque
toujours un bateau qui amène d'orient
une peste tout neuf nosferatu raconte le
schéma
[Musique]
la peste débarquera remontera les routes
les fleuves portés par ceux qui fuient
se transmettant comme une mauvaise
nouvelle
jusqu'à moscou jusqu'à londres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait on peut se mettre n'importe où
pour parler de la peste on peut être sûr
qu'elle est passée là où en est à gordes
comme ailleurs à gordes nous sommes
allés avec le docteur bira main ce qu'il
faut imaginer c'est que pendant trois
siècles les gens non seulement sont mort
de la peste mais ont vécu avec la peste
et ont tellement vécu avec la baisse que
finalement ce alors était quelque chose
qui leur passait assez indifférente
donner l'exemple de richelieu et de ses
troupes
oui on finissait par s'y accoutumer tout
individu connaissez au moins deux ou
trois postes dans son existence et vous
parliez de richelieu lors du siège de la
rochelle alors que la rochelle était
affecté et que les troupes de richelieu
qui a siégé étaient aussi affectés il
n'hésite pas lorsqu'il apprend que la
forteresse de cazals sentiers mot est
assiégée par les espagnols envoyé un
détachement de 2000 hommes qui va
traverser toute la france et se met la
peste à chaque endroit ça faisait partie
de la mentalité wind croyez que la peste
faisait partie de l'existant c'est que
tout le monde devait la brave et à un
moment ou un autre ce qui est formidable
c'est que des gens qui observent on fait
quand même un certain nombre de
remarques depuis très 148 ''sans marquée
entre autre que certains métiers étaient
plus menacé que d'autres et certains
métiers plus privilégiés que d'autres
c'est une observation courante
on observe que certaines professions
sont beaucoup plus gravement touchées en
particulier les boulangers les
équarrisseurs les bouchers sont ceux qui
paient un lourd tribut à la maladie à
l'époque on ne savait pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui on pense simplement que leur
dépôt de pain leurs dépôts de viande
attiré beaucoup les rats et que c'était
pour eux
une occasion supplémentaire d'être
contaminés inversement il ya des
professions dont le bruit faisait fuir
les rats et kit est épargné par exemple
les chaudronniers par exemple les
forgerons ou encore les tonneliers dans
les habitations des tables de près
déserté par les rats en trois siècles
légende eu le temps de mettre au point
certaines ongs de défense à la fois
individuelles et collectives
individuelles d'abord disons les
talismans l'établissement était la
première chose sur lequel on se
précipitait les puissants emporté comme
delambre de l'or des pierres précieuses
le rugby le diamant c'est l'origine
d'ailleurs de la bague de fiançailles
qui protégeait de la peste pour appuyer
les remèdes relativement traditionnel
recevant les processions les processions
ont été inventées à l'occasion de la
peste
[Musique]
c'est à lyon c'est 128 je crois à la
peste a lyon on a donc très envie de
faire les processions mais en même temps
on sait que c'est très mauvais que les
rassemblements sont dangereux et alors
c'est pas très bien quoi faire
finalement on demande aux gens de bourg
en bresse qui eux n'ont pas la peine de
faire une procession à la place des
lyonnais vieux on la paie est formidable
c'est la procession par procuration et
ça semblait aussi efficace c'est la
communion des saints les ceintures de
cire autour des villes à une invention
de montpellier s'adapte 13 174
montpellier eu l'idée d'abord de faire
un grand cierge calais d'un bout à
l'autre de la ville
puis il en faire un autre qui ceinturait
la ville entièrement et ça a été très
vite et on trouve des ceintures de cire
jusqu'au xviie siècle ce sont des
agissements sais qui tu brûles pendant
deux ans quelquefois alors bon ça ce
sont les remèdes disons de type
religieux puis il ya des romaine de type
militaire et sanitaires en même temps
les précautions prises toutefois très
très sérieuse et très bien même c'est
plus tard c'est à partir du moment où un
certain nombre de médecins et surtout
d'autorité commence à croire à la
contagion
et ce mouvement contagio nist qui
commence avec fracas steurs au début du
16e siècle prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur c'est ce qui oblige à empêcher
la fuite
la fuite c'était l'ère open en amenant
la contagion les gens s'enfuient y est
parce qu'il pensait que la contagion
tenait à l'ère du pays qui était malsain
à partir du moment où on a cru que
c'étaient les gens qui eux même
transporter la peste alors on a fait des
des cordons sanitaires qui ont empêché
les gens de fuir et petit à petit on a
contenu la peste dans ses limites
une corde ans hamid
en exemple de ding croise une pensée
aligne activement parce que c'est
vraiment un exemple des plus terribles
c'est l'époque où on commençait à voir
idée que les cordons sanitaires de
troupes pouvait empêcher la peste de
septembre mais comme ça n'était pas
encore organisé n'a pas hésité à bloquer
la ville de digne sans lui offrir de
ravitaillement et les gens ont souffert
autant de la famine que de la peste sur
10000 habitants digne a perdu 8 milles
au moins de ses habitants cinq seulement
n'ont pas une maladie dire que lorsque
quelqu'un de digne seuil est sorti on
lui tirer dessus c'est simple exactement
parallèlement à cela pendant marseille
comme exemple il ya des précautions qui
sont prises également à l'échelon du
port pour que la paix est en principe
puisse ne pas rentrer dans la ville dès
la fin du xvème siècle un lazareth été
installés lorsque les navires arrivés
ils devaient faire quarantaine mais en
les 720 ou marseille n'avait pas connu
la peste depuis combien de temps et
depuis des gens plus de 70 ans puisque
la dernière était de 549 et avant il ya
eu combien nous peste à marseille
j'en ai au moins 25 sur lesquels on a
des détails et probablement 34 alors
c'est difficile de savoir ce que
finalement est ce que les marseillais
avait complètement oublié qu'ils avaient
connu la peste ou nous on savait bien
que la peste existe et elle était
toujours au proche orient
à marseille même on y croyait peut-être
laisser aller est cuite qui n'aurait pas
dû exister
[Applaudissements]
on attendait moins condamnable poste est
arrivé à marseille
700 pers
elle est arrivée par un navire l'ait
legrand saint-antoine qui avait fait
escale au liban en route
il avait déjà perdu un passager cette
matelots lorsqu'il a fait escale à
livourne le port lui a refusé l'entrée
et lui a donné une patente brut
c'est-à-dire soupçons du passé d'abord
parce que pour le capitaine comment
s'appelait-il château pour le capitaine
château c'était un drame commerciale et
à fait être allé sa cargaison
et effectivement il apportait beaucoup
de toiles beaucoup d'indiennes beaucoup
de tissu qui devait selon dans la foire
de beaucaire et cette fois été prochaine
fallait donc absolument qu'ils puissent
décharger rapidement ses marchandises
qui pourrait être aujourd'hui estimée de
500 millions de nouveaux francs après
effectivement son arrivée à marseille
lille a été mis en quarantaine à lille
de pomègues c'était le 25 mai est
mystérieusement se demande pourquoi on
l'a autorisé à débarquer ces marchands
2g ses passagers dès le 3 juin je te
dira bien avant la fin d' actions
radiall viennent avant la ferme va
quarantaine dès cette date aussi on le
sait maintenant des matelots ont
commencé à vendre en contrebande des
tissus dans la ville
et c'est effectivement par des tailleurs
détail euse que la peste a commencé la
responsabilité si on a recherche sur la
rechercher je les assurés vont faire
processeur faire fait pour beaucoup
rechercher les échevins était très
compromis en particulier le premier
échevin estelle et qui avait beaucoup
d'intérêt dans cette cargaison est la
première victime de la poste dès le 21
juin il ya déjà une mort suspecte
rebelles table c'est le 28 juin
seulement il ya une mort certaine par
peste c'est un tailleur à 6 mg en kabyle
place ni palais reste entre le 21 juin
et le 14 juillet à marseille et il meurt
une vingtaine de personnes de la peste
mais une manière à quasi clandestine
enfin mais c'est pas on n'avoue pas
encore que c'est la paix depuis le 14
juillet dans cette rue de l'echelle un
certain nombre de décès et 17 juillet
par la cdc se produisent chez des
voisins de la news le tennis est une
femme qui soit celle d'une femme amta
nous voilà tu es décédé de la peste et
c'est qui ce qui commence à inquiéter
l'administration municipale pour la
première fois s'inquiète et envoie un
expert chose curieuse contre des
médecins agrégé marseillais et elle
envoie comme expert un certain bozon qui
était un simple chirurgien mais qui
avait connu la peste soit disant proche
orient et ce blouson déclare tout de go
qu'il s'agit là d'un simple fièvre vers
mineuse et puis dans la nuit du 21 au 22
juillet il ya un très violent orage et
bastille la peste se réveille la nuit du
21 au 22
il s'éleva un furieux orages mêlée de
pluie de grêle d'éclairs de tonnerre si
effrayant que personne ne se souvenait
d'en avoir entendu de si terrible et que
l'on crut qu'il avait été comme le
signal de la peste dieu déclarant ainsi
la guerre à son peuple
deux jours après il ya 14 morts d'un
coup on est obligé d'hospitaliser une
cinquantaine de personnes le lendemain
il ya encore huit morts dans les
infirmeries et à ce moment là vraiment
on s'inquiète beaucoup et la rue de
l'échelle et barricadé la rue de
l'échelle et barricadé le 27
le permis les jésuites s'enferme avec
les habitants pour les soigner à ce
moment là vraiment les événements se
précipitent ça devient la catastrophe le
1er août il ya déjà 50 morts par jour le
2 ou sur la demande des médecins
sicard perry fils de municipalité décide
le purifier l'air de marseille il fait
un embrasement général des remparts
ainsi aussi que petite once de soufre
dans chaque pièce que les pères de
famille doivent faire brûler
conséquences et conséquence rien du tout
sinon que le manque de bois amène les
boulangers à ne plus pouvoir faire cuire
leur pain est à faire monter le prix du
pain une émeute émeutes le 6 août qui
d'ailleurs à la conséquence heureux si
on peut dire d'obliger la municipalité à
prendre vraiment des mesures parce que
la fermeture des fabriques a réduit
beaucoup de gens au chômage et qu'à ce
moment là on doit vraiment organiser les
secours
c'est à ce moment là qu'on divise la
ville en secteur et que 150 commissaires
sont chargés de ravitailler la
population pauvre jusqu'au 5 où les
cadavres sont enlevés la nuit
oui pour ne pas affoler les populations
on avait pris cette décision d'enlever
les cadavres la nuit mais
quand ils deviennent trop nombreux est
obligé de les enlever le jour il est
obligé de croiser des fausses les
cimetières sont pleins on commence à
faire creuser des fosses
fosses communes qui ont deux mètres
cinquante de profondeur trois mètres
cinquante de large et quelquefois 40 ou
50 mètres de long
[Musique]
toutes les portes de la ville on peine à
suffire la foule de ceux qui sortent
presque tous les intendants de la santé
les conseillers de la ville et
commissaire de police
les artisans de tous métiers ceux qui
sont les plus nécessaires à la vie
les boulangers les vendeurs de vivre ces
denrées jusqu'à ce qu'ils doivent garder
les autres et les empêcher de quitter
c'est à dire les capitaines et officiers
de vie tout déserte tout abandonnent
tous fui
il meurt alors 300 personnes par jour
[Musique]
et le 15 ou le roi pardon région envoie
une commission médicale trois savants
médecins qui arrivent qui reste 24
heures exactement examine quelques
personnes il faut mettre des autopsies
leur diagnostic est clair c'est la peste
repartent mais ils repartent en catimini
l'engueuler on dit rien ce n'est que
trois jours plus tard que des affiches
sont posés disant qu'il s'agit
simplement d'une fièvre maligne la
doctrine officielle est toujours la même
par peur de faire peur le pouvoir ne dit
pas la vérité
le pouvoir pense que la peur tu autant
de gens que la peste les corbeaux vous
dites les corbeaux manque le camp besson
et croque mort encore de la poste oui ce
sont les croque-morts spécialisée dans
l'enlèvement des cadavres et
l'enterrement des canards de test
comment les recruteurs c'est difficile à
recruter généralement ou bien ce sont
des personnes dévouées mais il y en a
peu ou bien ce sont des gens qui sont
payés très cher
ou encore ce sont des prisonniers à qui
on a promis la liberté mais il meurt
très vite quatrième jour de travail il
mais c'est souvent ce qui se passe et en
particulier à marseille on compte que
lorsqu'on embauche un corbeau travail de
jour le troisième étant malade le
quatrième
[Musique]
du 20 au 25 ou les malades se
multiplièrent furieusement les échevins
sans secours et ne pouvant plus suffire
à faire enlever les cadavres on propose
à 2 expédients pour pouvoir en venir à
bout
l'un était de creuser des fosses
profondes dans toutes les places
publiques et les rues afin d'ensevelir
les morts sur le lieu maison fut en même
temps réflexion qu'on a les corrompre
les eaux de la ville l'autre était de
jeter tous les morts dans un vaisseau et
de l'allée ensuite coulé ba en pleines
mais maison considéra que la maladie
augmentant tous les jours il aurait
fallu un bâtiment toutes les semaines et
que d'ailleurs de longtemps on n'aurait
plus voulu manger de poisson
de sorte que ces deux projets furent
abandonnées il meurt alors 500 personnes
par jour
vous écrivez les malades qui souhaite
lui pense entrée à l'hôpital des
convalescences s'allonge sur le court
une couvre la chaussée se dire
finalement les hôpitaux dans ce refuge
du mondial entend des musulmans la
raison pour laquelle l'intérieur des
hôpitaux étaient probablement encore
plus horrible à voir que l'accès et qui
soignait besoin de vous parler dans le
fond de quelques fois qu'ils ont 12 ans
c'était des volontaires essentiellement
parce que le personnel hospitalier était
complètement débordé et parmi ces
volontaires il y avait de tout jeunes
enfants dont quelques-uns avaient 12 à
son bord
[Musique]
outre les crimes énorme qui se
commettent publiquement dans la ville où
il n'y a plus de pudeur les hôpitaux ou
même sont devenus les tabernacles des
pêcheurs la mort est presque toujours la
solde de la fornication de l'adultère du
viol ya de même un certain nombre
d'endroits préserver dans un seuil il y
en a peu regarde un peu puisque 83% des
maisons ont été affectées
il ya cependant le l'abbaye saint victor
les chanoines se sont retirés tout dire
mais soigneusement fermé clos et qui
sait sont libres et à la revente prière
pour la cessation du fléau qui ont donné
généreusement d'ailleurs mais pas de
leurs personnes
il y a eu des courageux aussi aux
chanoines de saint-victor s'oppose le
permis les on l'a dit qui s'est laissée
barricadés dans la rue de l'échelle pour
ne pas laisser les mourants sans
sacrements il y a eu les vagues belsunce
il a écrit ce qu'il a fait j'ai vu et
senti pendant huit jours 200 morts
pourrissant autour de ma maison est sous
ma femme
j'ai été obligé de marcher dans les rues
toutes sans exception bordée des deux
côtés de cadavres à demi pour y est
rongée par les chiens et le milieu plein
de hard de pestiférés et d'ordures à ne
savoir où mettre le pied
il me fallait traverser ces cadavres aux
infectés pour confesser et consoler les
moribonds jeté hors de leur maison est
placée parmi les morts sur des matelas
[Musique]
il meurt alors mille personnes par jour
à marseille
la ville ne peut plus supporter ces
cadavres
elle s'acharne à les faire disparaître
mais il y en a toujours deux nouveaux à
certains endroits il y en a tellement et
depuis si longtemps qu'il faut un
courage fou pour les enlever ainsi place
de la tourette défaut le courage fou du
chevalier roze pour dégager la place de
la tourette que 12 100 cadavres rendre
inaccessible on donne aux chevaliers aux
50 force à une compagnie de soldats des
galères pour les conduire mais peut-être
aurait-il reculer sans entrer en lice si
le chevalier roze descendu de cheval du
prix lui même par une jambe le premier
cadavre qui se présenta pour leur tracer
la route qu'ils devaient suivre à
l'instant il se livrèrent aux dangers
avec une ardeur incroyable
tantôt ils saisissent un trou pour y ont
les bras et les jambes se sont détachés
et leur sont restés dans les mains
tantôt une marge sur des corps morts
dans lesquelles le pied s'enfonce comme
dans la boue tout le monde enfin travail
avec tant de courage que ce jour là même
la place se trouve entièrement net
[Musique]
le 16 septembre marseille est une ville
morte
[Musique]
la peste mais autant de temps pour
disparaître qu'elle en a mis pour
atteindra son paroxysme
presque trois mois un jour enfin les
survivants comprennent que le mal est
parti d'abord il ya le nombre des morts
quotidiens que tout le monde sait il ya
aussi le fait qu'il ya davantage de
guérit sans doute que le virus soit
moins grave
et puis surtout pour la peste de 1720
sait qui a été extraordinaire
c'est la joie des gens de voir
réapparaître le corbillard en plaçant
les tombereaux qui jusque là avait
l'habitude d'emporter les morts il y
aura presque a paru de retour de ce
corps milliards était quand même le
symbole de la vie normale retrouver la
mort naturelle la mort naturelle
on a applaudi les corbillards avec des
cris de joie
après avoir perdu la moitié de ses
habitants 50 mille morts
marseillan d'iso par l'immigration
retrouvera sa population d'avoir la
catastrophe mais dès la fin de
l'épidémie au veulent l'oublier en 1722
marseille avait recouvré presque tout
son lustre dont l'éclat faisait
l'admiration de nos voisins l'académie
de musique et la comédie était rétabli
les balles et les mariages pompeux
fournissait de si fréquentes fait que
les plaisirs avait fait oublier les
horreurs de cette sangle on avait
tellement banni la peste de la
conversation que lorsqu'une personne sa
vie z en parlait dans une compagnie
chacun s'écrier comment vous osez
renouveler ses entretiens fâché et
chacun tournant la tête ou le vent les
les prout on obligeait monsieur
l'indiscret c'était
à marseille aujourd'hui encore comme
dans tous les ports on se méfie de la
peste le contrôle sanitaire aux
frontières capte et examine chaque jour
un certain nombre de rats c'est que la
peste n'est pas un mal disparu il faut
être vigilant à l'institut pasteur
le professeur molard et le 10 à partir
de 1894 il y à une nouvelle épidémie
mondiale entrait 148 on sait qu est-ce
qui a apporté les rails les plus ce sont
les vaisseaux génois fair 1894 qu'est ce
qui s'est passé s'est passé une
révolution sans précédent dans
l'histoire de la peste les vaisseaux
génois les lourdes 9 huissière à voile
et est remplacé par la navigation à
vapeur et alors que la marine à voile ne
pouvait faire que du cabotage
transporter le port rapport la peste la
marine à vapeur a fait ce qu'il ne
pouvait pas être fait auparavant
elle a transporté 2 continent à
continent des rats infectés des puces
infectées
cette épidémie elle dure toujours
oui cette épidémie partie de hong kong
en 94 c'est ce qu'on appelle la
troisième temps des demis et c'est celle
dans laquelle nous sommes encore à
présent à partir de 98 la peste a
débarqué dans tous les ports d'europe
les derniers cas de peste à paris qui
doivent être considérées comme un porc
mai dernier quand son bras si dieu
puisque c'est la fameuse peste des
chiffonniers
fois au nord de paris qui remonte à 1920
aujourd'hui le vase
la chine a la côte ouest des états unis
eh bien on retrouve dans cette situation
actuelle d'une part les vieux foyer
traditionnel c'est-à-dire pratiquement
tout ce centre de l'asie l'ancien foyer
centrafricains qui n'est que le reliquat
de la peste dit justinien de la peste du
siècle du pourtour méditerranéen qui est
descendue jusque là qui a laissé ce
foyer qui persiste toujours
puis deuxièmement vous avez les soyez né
de la troisième pandémie c'est à dire
les normes voiliers de l'afrique du sud
les foyers de l'est afrique à la
tanzanie
vous avez le foyer de l'ouest ça rien et
qui est un foyer qui serait réel nous il
ya maintenant cinq ans seulement
et puis nous n'avons et cet énorme de
foyers américains qui est né en janvier
1920 à san francisco et voiliers de 1901
à 1974 elle a fait un peu plus de la
moitié du chemin san francisco new york
invite à contacter le matin par la peste
et puis deux ans elle a franchi la
limite la frontière du canada au nord du
mexique ou du sud comme toujours il faut
se dire que ces zones de l'est sont des
zones de brest chez les rongeurs mais
que dans la mesure où le contact il
toujours possible entre l'homme et
défricheur il ya périodiquement des
quatre est humaine pourriez vous citer
un exemple récent où les pertes en vies
humaines ont été considérables
l'épidémie de peste qui est survenu en
floride en hiver
1910 1911 qui a fait plusieurs dizaines
de milliers victimes de peste pulmonaire
en l'espace de quelques semaines
[Musique]
si vous cherchez des chiffres
malheureusement il ya l'exemple de
lincou pratiquement depuis le début du
siècle jusqu'en 1948
il n'a pas été dénombrés moins de 12
millions et demi de cap mordent est
maintenant au nombre malheureusement
encore très bien le test et dans le sud
est asiatique puisque vous voyez que le
sud vietnam le mans mode son document de
l'homme on enregistre plusieurs milliers
de cas de peste humaine chaque année
quels sont les moyens de lutte actuelles
après les grands espoirs nés de la
vaccination
nous possédons maintenant vraiment avec
d'une part les sulfamides d'autre part
les antibiotiques une arme très très
remarquable et parmi les antibiotiques
nous avons la streptomycine qui est la
numéro 1 qui est valable dans toutes les
formes de peste mais à condition d'être
administrés très précocement
peut-on dire aujourd'hui l'on a tort de
ne pas avoir à l'esprit de la peste oui
on a tort car il faut pas oublier
maintenant qu'avec le grand nombre de
gens qui voyagent qu'avec l'extrême
rapidité des moyens de transport à tout
moment en n'importe quel point du monde
un individu en incubation de peste peut
débarquer et a présenté un risque de
contamination interhumaine après la
marine à vapeur les avions les avions
pris le relais et il n'y a pas seulement
le voyageur venant d'une zone d'endémie
et incluent banc la peste dans son
voyage et voyant la maladie éclaté dans
la ville où leur a débarqué qui un
deuxième risque c'est le risque des
transports par container c'est énorme
containers dans lesquels on vante assez
des tonnes et des tonnes de grains par
exemple
pour aller débarquer à des milliers
kilomètres de là dans l'arrière-pays
il est possible d'avoir le risque de
l'embarquement d'un rare ou d'une puce
infectée est une nouvelle forme de
risques nés de nouveau moyen de
transport
[Musique]